welcome back
i'm here with gina ashley and abby three
single ladies who are beautiful
looking for love on dating apps and
something i am personally fascinated by
we want to bring in an expert who can
give some advice who met her husband on
a dating website
but she's an amazing coach demona
hoffman
hello
thank you demona i mean you are this
symbol of hope
you met your husband on a dating website
yes it was a site called nerve.com not
nerd.com
but nerve way back in 2003 when we
didn't even have smartphones
drew so i had to go to kinko's to scan
my photo
in and if if that doesn't give everyone
hope
that i went through those lengths to
find love and it worked for me i don't
know what will
and you guys are still together still
together
two kids happy life it's everything i
dreamed of that i didn't think was even
possible way back then
so okay ladies i want you to be able to
ask demona one question
each so we're gonna start uh with gina
okay hi jamona hello so
my question is when should we really
bring
up what we're truly looking for so for
me my end game is i want to get married
i want to have kids
and i feel like i craft my answer so
much when someone asks me what i'm
looking for and i just say
oh i just want to meet someone and enjoy
my time with them so i don't say
yeah i want to get married and have kids
i don't expect a ring in two weeks or
anything but
i think it scares them off if they think
that you want to be too serious
and so i'm just curious when should we
bring that kind of question up
i would say if you're putting out that
you aren't really looking for anything
serious or trying to play it too cool
you're probably getting guys
that aren't that serious am i right um
so
yeah we want to state our business up
front because the guys that run away
you don't want them anyway and you don't
want them wasting your time but we don't
do this because
ultimately we're afraid of rejection the
way i look at it rejection
is your protection it's saving you a lot
of time and a lot of stress from being
with people who don't want the same
things
so here's what i want you to do i want
you to be very clear from the beginning
you can be clear and cute you don't have
to say like i want to be married and
have two kids in two years from now
but you can say serious inquiries only
and you can be consistent in your
messaging across the app and also
when you move offline and on to the date
damona demona demona i totally agree
rejection is your protection
okay gina go ahead i mean sorry ashley
go ahead
that's fine hi damona so hello
i'm from houston i'm a true southern
bale
by like every single definition and i
feel like the man is supposed to be the
aggressor so i got on bumble and
immediately got off because the woman is
supposed to you know
go after the guy and my friends have
told me maybe that's not the 2020 way to
do it
so am i wrong should i be more
aggressive or
what am i doing wrong obviously i'm
doing something wrong
okay okay actually there's a big
difference between being
aggressive and being assertive so first
when you
are initiating messages and you're being
really active on the app it's actually
telling the app to give you more of what
you want
and less of what you don't the second
thing is that women who lead
always win you don't want to get in that
place of chasing there are a lot of
thirsty women out there that are chasing
there's a big difference i'm just
talking about
you know the digital dropping the hanky
and saying hello i'm here
and now inspiring him to show up for you
ashley and letting him know
how you want him to take the lead from
this point forward
digital dropping the hanky yeah
abby ask this amazing
guru your question
i like to research the guys i match with
if i can get
little crumbs of details about them once
we match
like oh he's a doctor his name is scott
he lives in new york and i'll
google it and i'll find his linkedin and
i'll find his facebook and i'll see if
we have friends in common
like reading his college thesis essay
is this a good practice to have should i
dial it back
what should i be doing abby i think you
answered your own question right there i
would say
that's way too much research you're
dating you're not starting a detective
agency okay
when people do all of this research
what's really happening is that we're
looking for reasons to say
no rather than reasons to say yes
my tip would be instead of doing all of
that google research
just ask for a phone call or a video
chat date up front
and then all you need to figure out is
that he has your three
must-have qualities and notice i did not
say 75
i said three must-have qualities and
that he doesn't have your one deal
breaker
that's all you need to know before you
actually meet up in person
and let the magic and the mystery unfold
that sounds a lot simpler and healthier
right i mean we make it so hard we make
it harder on ourselves and we think
that there's like some some mythical
magical
formula to doing it but really it's all
about just being authentic
and staying in the moment staying
curious and
looking at it as so much opportunity
there's never been a better time
in history for a woman to be single and
i love that you all have so much choice
and when you have clarity on what you're
looking for and you go out and get it
i want you to write me and and send me a
thank you note and maybe a wedding
invitation and i'll be there
you got it
you